lexie et l'un des dix mille animaux
sauvé par le refuge des fidèles
moustachu depuis leurs débuts
heureusement elle est tombée sur une
nouvelle famille dévouée mais s'informer
toute la semaine pour savoir si quand
est-ce que tu as la lite vacciné et
vermifugé tout tibet la fin de la
semaine et j'avais la chercher comme
qu'elles devaient être connus plus bas
j'ai des amis à la maison avec moi mais
tous n'ont pas la chance de trouver le
foyer qui leur convient l'abandon
d'animaux demeure une importante
problématique au québec en particulier
lors des déménagements toujours aussi
présent malheureusement malgré le fait
que beaucoup plus de sensibilisation
beaucoup plus c'est beaucoup plus parlé
sont peut-être mais j'ai toujours
beaucoup d'abandons dans les rues lors
des déménagements beaucoup de personnes
qui laissent leurs animaux dans les
appartements chaque année des milliers
d'entre eux sont abandonnés par leur
famille durant cette période selon
l'association des médecins vétérinaires
du québec
c'est jusqu'à trois fois plus qu'à
d'autres moments de l'année c'est pas
toujours facile mais soit on y prend
sens pas assez à l'avancé on est capable
le dessus comme critère pour déménager
que notre a du mal ou des fois c'est
d'essayer de trouver le dans les
collègues de travail la famille dumont
possible de donner la pire chose à faire
c'est de le mettre dans la roue le
laisser dans l'appartement parce que
l'analyse laisse à lubango sais pas ce
qui va lui arriver abandonné l'animal
dans des circonstances qui met sa vie en
danger et d'ailleurs puni par la loi
depuis 2015 la loi sur le bien-être et
la sécurité de l'animal prévoit des
amendes très salée pour certaines
infractions allant jusqu'à des dizaines
de milliers de dollars
et si les abos chaîne radio canada
québec